[Music]
this week we've got what a tip travel
nightmare and disruptive pancakes
I hate when pancakes too to disrupt you
ha that's all my french toast person
good for you I love pancakes they can
disrupt me anytime waffles I like what
was it today baby like this you can go
in a pancakes are done well though it's
hard to be yeah before we get into the
pan key conversation let's go back to
the themes years I [ __ ] it up you can
blame me on that one I [ __ ] lame blame
blame blame just the tip or something I
like that too yeah it's a proper story
there is I don't like to do you guys
like mushroom caps or Nazi helmets
what's yours
I don't know but some of them are
different I thought well going back to
the article gel-like hang that on yeah
okay I was gonna compliment Bart oh wow
I messed that up you did like the first
time ever Wow sorry Bart
I know that's it we're done there's this
man named Mike from Seattle who tipped
$300 which is 39% on his seven hundred
and $69 meal Wow that's a meal he went
into the kitchen and gave each of the 17
kitchen staff members a $100 bill and
praised them for the service in it so he
violated food code I know you're not
supposed to walk back there I brought
dirty currency into a kitchen I know the
cooks have to touch that $100 bill
what if he gave anything like a stripper
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
highest [ __ ] for sure
so the general manager said this it was
amazing to have that happen unexpectedly
and randomly and for someone to show
that amount of pre-shave appreciation
it's not just about the money but
spending time with people in the kitchen
and telling them how wonderful of a meal
it was and wasting their time cuts to be
doing what they're doing because I'm
like this is awesome gesture but I think
it's because my restaurant humor comes
out because I know how [ __ ] hectic
it's crazy if a [ __ ] came back
there it started handing people a
hundred dollar bills and and taking
people like away from their [ __ ] that
they need to be cooking right now to
have a conversation and praise them it's
like damn dude there's customers waiting
it's like what lessons between 2:00 p.m.
and 4:00 p.m.
those are the that's the worst time this
is the only time because we're prepping
they're not time that's true oh yeah
whatever that's the end of the night
like kind of like he just was it at the
end of the night or did he just write at
the end of the night everyone's trying
to [ __ ] clean the [ __ ] up and go the
[ __ ] home and they don't even allow
customers in the kitchen so yeah shoes
yeah you have to have shoes for crews
I've been there I'm ruining the joy but
to me it's just the hilarious scene
because that foot would have never been
able to get in the back of my restaurant
I think it's an amazing gesture but I'm
just thinking like you don't in and out
on a busy day it's [ __ ] chaos and you
got a guy that's going back there hey a
nice potato cruncher you got going on
kind of dogs do you like out of here I
can't make enough leg I just picture
this really open open shirt a hairy
Armenian guy the gold chain that comes
in you know and he pulled the collar a
lot of the kitchen staff doesn't even
get paid a hundred bucks a day so that's
actually a lot where is he so he's right
here I wouldn't give it to every single
person yes a hundred dollars for each
person plus $200 tip is it the bald guy
close the two grand yeah it's definitely
not a it's not a Denny's what then and
then did he go to a reporter and say I
just did this at a restaurant read an
article about me I'm curious to like how
does media find out about furries like
this but they never tell you there might
be like one of the restaurant workers
that are like hey this guy came in and
did this thing I mean who knows like
with with everyone on social media now
it's like the information gets out I
think it's pretty awesome that someone
would do this because a lot of the times
I think the wrong person gets in trouble
like in a restaurant or like though the
wrong person gets the praised yeah
sometimes it's like a waiter right the
waiter is not responsible for seating
you they could have [ __ ] that up the
host could have [ __ ] that up
mm-hmm it's not the waiters fault the
food sucks but then they get all the
[ __ ] or if the food took a long time
yeah waiter gets blamed for oh my god I
was a waiter for 11 years and it was
it's not easy tip your waiters yeah if
they're like slacking off like it's okay
to like tip them less because like
sometimes like go to a restaurant and I
could tell Steve like no our guys
slacking off like there's nobody in here
yep I understand when people get slammed
with tables but if there's no one in
there and you can't even refill a water
the whole time yeah pretty much
Oh tip is very much contingent on your
service for me anyways like I'll always
give a little something but if it's
terrible service you're gonna get like
12 cents and like you'll know that I was
very very upset my idea of a bad tip
though is like 15% so I bet they came
here I still know I can't do it like
anymore I can't do under 15% I can easy
but you know what I also I also gauge
the culture and I also gauge their
intelligence
yeah cuz I go this guy's full-blown
[ __ ] dub there's no way that gives
them a hundreds of dollars I'm just like
there's no way this fool is doing his
best it's slow but this is their [ __ ]
dumb like they're not gonna get better
so I'm just I'm just like whatever
there's no point for me to get angles of
good men $0.12 yeah that's very nice of
you that's all you get
they're mentioning here that Mike was
having dinner with five other dinner
companions and they didn't tape home
yeah I don't know maybe you just pay for
everyone
maybe he's one of those geysers like I
would treat about my friends for he pays
to have friends no it's a really cool
dude yeah cuz then after dinner they
went through a catch a show I don't know
what show but you guys don't give bad
tip to people who give you [ __ ] a
service well if they're rude to me than
I think I started doing it so I'm kind
of like Joe or it's like 15% no matter
what at a restaurant but you do good 20
maybe 25 percent yeah what I did start
doing lower than 15 percent was cuz
after you told me how if people [ __ ]
your post meets up that's when I started
doing some post mates if you bring the
wrong order or if you come and I ordered
curry and that [ __ ] is like outside of
the container and it's in the back yeah
then I started going zero there's like
some [ __ ] dude like for example I
was at said place which I don't go
anymore
I'm not gonna bash the business but the
waiter whether you didn't say it was
well the food was like all [ __ ] up the
Khan said okay said restaurant food
wasn't right right it wasn't what I
ordered and the person argued that that
I ordered was it no it wasn't okay and
they're like I was like nah bro it's not
what I ordered they're like [ __ ] and he
rolled his eyes I was like oh [ __ ] it's
like and I could hear them in the back
talking about like I'm like a cheap
[ __ ] cut it's a [ __ ] burger you
[ __ ] it's not that expensive and so
that's why they got zero you know and I
mean and [ __ ] like out there
talking to like the hostess at the bar
just like chatting it up with my [ __ ]
drinks right here talking to her [ __ ]
yeah you're not getting [ __ ] dude so
recently we went we had this wrap party
and it was like an open bar and it was
the holiday season so we were at this
restaurant and a open bar party was in
the back and I always feel bad for the
open part of an bar bar tenders because
people think that if the drinks are free
they don't have to tip
so I always like go over and I tip them
more than than I even would usually tip
on drinks because the doors are free and
like you're working a lot of people
aren't tipping so I didn't know that
yeah yes I was like hooking this guy up
every time I got drinks I either do it
one way like I used to do it where I
dropped a 20 at the beginning of the
night and then I'd give more like
towards the end but now like after a few
bad experiences like this dude I won't
do it anymore so I usually tip like 5
bucks a drink like more than yeah
because because like if the drinks are
free and they're working okay no one's
tipping so I go up there and like I
order a drink I'm like hey what do you
got like just I want something festive
it's holidays or whatever he makes a
drink it tastes like [ __ ] but I still
tip him well and I'm like okay whatever
it's like this weird chocolatey this guy
does not know how to pour a good drink
maybe I'm judgmental cuz I could pour a
really good drink but I'm like I run
into a friend they just got there I'm
like oh let me get you a let's go get a
drink and so I go back up to the same
guy we had already had a conversation
and he's like I need to see your ID
and I was like oh he's like um are you
21 now that's what he said he's like are
you 20 you served me this [ __ ] drink
did you forget yeah he looks at my
friend he's like are you 21 and he's
like yeah and then he looks at me he's
like are you 21 and I was like no you
just served me a drink and he's like all
right I'm giving you a drink and not you
and I was like and I had the tip in my
hand and I was like all right I'm going
inside to get a drink by I was gonna tip
you like lots throughout the night but
it's just good like that guy's a [ __ ]
dick I wish I could've taped my old tip
back you what I do when those situations
not like that situation but when I tip
somebody I time it so they could see it
I might say with the strippers yeah you
better see if I tipped you generously
because I'm a good person
maybe that's I told him though I was
like Joe do you not remember two seconds
ago when I was here and you gave me a
drink and I tipped you and everything
and we were cool okay because I remember
that and then I wouldn't I went inside
and I was like I'm literally never
ordering a drink from that guy at the
the rest of the night I don't give a
[ __ ] but the drinks are free out here
and have to pay and that would spit in
his tip jar here's your tip
all right for our next story here
there were tourists that were stranded
in Mexico
oh no that's like the worst in our
composite 250 American shut up
it is pretty never taking you to Mexico
Mexico never oh no you can never go to
Mexico Maura the two of you why me of
all the hard even I sir about the home
like he just said oh no no I've been to
Mexico and I've helped a lot of homeless
children
you were saying oh no for the stranded
part right yeah I could talk [ __ ]
because I've been to Mexico to help
people - you went to the words of metal
but I did I did the loving thing because
you wanted to know you were for married
a Mexican everybody so everybody here
it's the ax that counts right I remember
when I was at Tijuana right that's the
one [ __ ] [ __ ] of mine why are you
being disrespectful to teethe woman's
that's what she wanted she could vouch
for I've been saying these days the fun
I did so we're bad for saying that it
sucks yeah cuz you're not no Beverly
Hills in Mexico the most craziest
saddest time ever because there was this
little boy that wasn't straight dollars
and the stray dog almost bit me the
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and I said oh my
god I'm scared and a little boy looked
at me he goes don't be scared God is
with you I was like oh and I cried like
now give me money well no he was my
little guide so I want to see effects
akin pyramids yeah great I went it was
scary though cuz like if you look down
the stairs are really seeing I thought
you were scared of the drug cartel or
something oh that I mean that's no but
you look Mexican though you find them I
know people mom yes
but they do that here oh it's like old
Mexican ladies get so [ __ ] mad at me
I got yelled at by so many old next you
don't know Spanish yeah because I guess
that's a thing I don't know your
co-generation has it no Spanish and so
they get pissed if young people a new
thing it's been around forever oh you
don't know if you are Mexican you don't
Spanish yeah
they're [ __ ] go [ __ ] well I don't
Spanish and this is these ladies they
start yelling at me first so speaking
Spanish I don't know the answer and I'm
like no habla espanol
right because that's the only Spanish I
know and there they Kate they go off on
me in English like [ __ ] I'm Filipino
part Filipino [ __ ] I tell them that and
then they go will you look Mexican oh
but it's your fault like so you should
know Spanish that's all I can't win then
I don't know tell you where you use
pesos to there's this regional airline
called Sun country fun country fun
country in America some country sucks
dicks my friends were abandoned was
stranded they were stranded on New
Year's they're supposed to host our new
the New Year's party and they were
stranded because the [ __ ] Sun country
is it like spirit 50 Americans were
stranded in Mexico because Sun could
they over booked their flight no that's
why flights to Mexico it's only seasonal
and so their last flight they had to
cancel it because they were servicing
Minnesota and that's where they my
friends were being stranded in Minnesota
yes then currently like because of what
weather conditions they had to cancel
that last flight and since that was the
very last flight of that season that
means everyone that was on the flight is
just [ __ ] like they just at least they
got a refund but they still have to find
their own way to get a refund but they
have to pay to stay stay somewhere in
Mexico until they can get back and if
you're buying a flight like next day
it's crazy expense and if you're getting
a budget airline like that that means
you already don't have that kind of
money
exactly so like there's this story about
this one particular family that was on
that flight and they spent another two
days in Mexico and it costs them way
more money it cost them about $2,000 oh
[ __ ] with like the flight home the
rental car the hotel the taxicabs
everything have to miss work yeah yeah
I'd feel safer what a Mexican drug
cartel then to take that airline
guaranteed they'll take me to America if
I pay them I'll be like mr. Coyle pay
sir can you please take me back to
America
they're not gonna miss the flight
they're gonna take me back especially if
you're gonna smuggle some [ __ ] in your
butt free of charge man just put this in
your [ __ ] booty hole you're there
yeah my butt's not that loose yeah maybe
when I'm 50 I kind of want to test it
should I try to see if I could stick
like a little chap stick up my butt you
can't though that's really small every
time I come here it's something that you
want to trap it just to see what you're
all about you know if you want to
squeeze a heart throbbing big dick no
just these oh it's not just these
anybody anybody I thought no a big dick
feels like and apparently he doesn't
have a big dick did we hear from someone
that he has a Kasota Candace did not
hear someone else whatever she's an
older friend of mine but her her friends
was like one of those like basketball
hoes or whatever and hooked up with Shaq
and she said that his dick was like
wasn't ready as long as she thought it
was but it was really wide like a Saudi
kid all right for our last story here
there was this teacher at this middle
span cakes yeah thank you
[ __ ] yeah yeah so this teacher at this
middle school was 8th grade social
studies teacher so he brought to school
a portable griddle and he started making
pancakes for his students as they were
taking this very important test
god damn but it's not so good in there
yeah they call him like good we actually
exist
no yeah Savannah he was making pancakes
for them and then apparently like some
other teacher like found out and then
the principal walks and the assistant
principal walks in and that's when the
teacher got in trouble the next day he
didn't show up and then the students
were so sad because they knew that he
got in trouble for that and apparently
the reason why he got in trouble like
they were even there were talks about
terminating he was picking his butt
while making the pancakes no there he
was coming into the pancake wrong with
you people try to figure out why you
would get in trouble yeah it has to be
severe right so he got in trouble
because his duty is to be vigilant of
the test takers and so if he's making
people could be cheese distracting so
they were saying that these were
distracting that sounds ridiculous yeah
they just don't look great is this for
eighth grade then who the [ __ ] here
exactly
it's eighth grade and not only that but
like everyone loves this huge early
because he sets the standard and now
everyone all the kids are gonna expect
that so they don't like you know Oh like
he's the favorite yeah they have to be
the bad guy yeah it's like I follow the
rules and I'm [ __ ] strict but I'm the
[ __ ] you know to me you know I cheated
a lot throughout junior high in high
school that's the teachers I liked the
most
I didn't cheat in those classes because
I felt bad the one connection with them
yeah the ones that didn't give a [ __ ]
about oh god I cheated like a mother
[ __ ] dude I cheated for no reason I
would write my friend's name on my test
they would call a mr. Beiler here they
would call them the eighth grade dad
because he was just so like carrying and
like he was so involved in his with his
students and stuff and so he got he was
suspended without pay they don't even do
that the cops back you people exactly
what the [ __ ]
I'm just making pancake yeah oh you
didn't making pancakes and then so the
students were so upset over this that
they even started like protesting yeah
pretty much yeah justice for pancakes
ringback Pilar this is cinnamon toast
question like colors that's cute they
don't know how to hashtag properly they
put a space that's cute they don't know
how to hashtag that shows how bad of a
teacher is that be so funny like it's
just proof that how bad of a teacher is
because there's so many typos and all
the signs and [ __ ] all those kids are
dumb as [ __ ] like we want pancakes back
I know it is spelt with a B the students
were saying that once the assistant
principal walked in she was the one that
was distracting because as soon as she
walked in that's when everyone started
flashing her titties everyone oh no they
stopped during their test and they just
looked over like she was the one that
was causing the distraction here so but
now they're saying so they had this
meeting with the school board Wow yeah
it went to that over pancakes exactly
well I mean we all know how [ __ ] pity
the school administration could be I
hope everything else is perfect yeah
they have paper towels stock no one's
getting into fights
oh my go you go right the paper towel
sometimes you go to that thing and
you're like where's the [ __ ] paper oh
yeah that [ __ ] little pedal spindle
that's like this big and [ __ ] motion
sensor was an elementary school [ __ ]
spoiled brat I don't know
they shouldn't yeah we knew they
restocked that powder so that life
anymore
they don't know they don't know that
they don't do that they got real soap
now I'll get exfoliate your hands with
that [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] salty ever
washed my hands in elementary because I
hated that soap so much I don't even
think I know what this whole be like
it's like you don't know it's like you
know the something it comes out and it's
like sand yeah and it smells bad I still
remember the smell yeah I don't know
that smell - did you guys have to run
the water for like ten seconds before
you drank it because it came out brown
did you live just let it run and then
you can drink the water I went to 186
Street school in Gardena California
because no one drank water so just sat
in the rusty but it was my class and we
had a sink with the water fountain but
not all the not all of them are like the
wait 10 seconds - so the waters not
[ __ ] up pipes we had a way just cuz
this kid would spit in the yes yeah
just like are they put their entire man
yeah those [ __ ] weird [ __ ] dumbass
kids like Dobby on the water fountain
they'll be like Mike it's not the suck
on you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you make
you got a big mouth but maybe it's by
accident not gonna do it oh dude
yes anyway we found out here that Tyler
is not gonna get fired
and he's he's returned to work yeah it's
not a lot to make pancakes [ __ ] party
pooping ass [ __ ] you know and there
isn't even a rule against serving food
anyway for whatever I mean man they just
hang in they just being hazed
[Music]